MATTHEW BERNARDO: So I'm
Matthew Bernardo.
I'm the Chief Development
Officer for Housing Works.
And today, we're going to talk
a little bit about Housing
Works and our journey through
social enterprise.
And really how it affected our
culture, and really how it
shaped the organization.
So our mission is simple.
It's to fight and to end
AIDS and homelessness.
And we do this through
relentless advocacy.
We do this through
entrepreneurial services.
And we do it through providing
lifesaving services.
So a lot of people know about
our stores, and a lot of
people might know about
our Bookstore Cafe.
There might be some that know
about our advocacy.
We have sort of a fierce
advocacy that
comes out of ACT UP.
Many politicians may know about
it because we're always
out on the streets
protesting them.
There's a third part of our
business that is actually our
largest part, and that's
our health services.
And they're really services that
wrap around our client.
They're mental health, they're
dental, they're primary care,
they're adult health
care centers.
And really, the purpose of this
is a lot of our clients
come to us with multiple
problems.
HIV/AIDS actually could be down
on the list for many.
There's homelessness, there's
mental illness, there's
substance abuse.
And the idea is that our clients
come and they meet all
this sort of love and holding
environment, in which Housing
Works Services provide.
Housing Works is actually
the largest AIDS service
organization in New
York state.
And this is probably the least
known of our business, but
it's one of the most
important.
So to tell the story about
Housing Works, we have to go
back to 1990.
That's when the AIDS crisis
was really full throttle.
People were dying at
an alarming rate.
There was really no hope in
sight for treatment or a cure.
And when you got an AIDS
diagnosis in 1990, you had
about six months to live.
So this was the environment in
which we were working at.
And to tell the story about
AIDS, you really have to tell
a story about ACT UP.
ACT UP was really the first
reaction that was very
visceral to demanding services
and funding and a way forward
for the HIV/AIDS crisis.
Housing Works actually started
out of ACT UP.
It started as a housing
committee of ACT UP.
And we were particularly
interested in people that were
actually dying on the streets
because they were homeless.
So if you were homeless and
you had AIDS, you had two
things either happen.
You either were discriminated
against because they weren't
giving housing to people
with HIV and AIDS.
And if you were lucky to get
into one of the city shelters
or one of the city housing,
you basically had rules.
So you had six months to live,
but you had a rule that you
had to be sober for
four months.
So if you think of it, what kind
of motivation for someone
that was struggling with
substance abuse that had AIDS,
that they had to get sober for
four months so they could die
in their house for
the last two?
So it really was something that
Housing Works set out and
was determined to house
these people.
So on the right, you can
actually see this painting.
And this hangs in one of our
first housing units.
And it really is about the
chaotic nature of the shelter
system in New York City.
And what we were trying to do
at Housing Works was to
migrate away from that and
really come up with housing
with dignity, housing that was
independent, and housing that
had the services right
there, so people
could survive and thrive.
So we started getting our
community together of people
we wanted to house,
and we started
incorporating ourselves.
And the idea was--
I think it was $500.
We raised our first $500 to get
the Housing Works name.
And we also had a theory.
And our theory was that if
you have stable housing,
the rest will come.
But you can't do anything
if you're not housed.
So if you think about people
that you want to keep them on
drug regiments, or you want
them to be in a substance
abuse program, they're not going
to do it if they don't
have a place to lay their head
or get up in the morning.
So that's basically been the
theory that Housing Works
really set out to solve
and to prove.
And we've been proving
it with much success
for the next 20 years.
So back to the '90s.
So everyone was coming
out of ACT UP.
Lots of AIDS service
organizations
came out of ACT UP.
And there was a really
scramble for funding.
So at that time, you had
God's Love We Deliver.
You had Gay Men's
Health Crisis.
You had amfAR.
And there was a tremendous
amount of competitiveness for
AIDS funding.
And Housing Works wasn't doing
so well in the traditional
fundraising realm.
We actually didn't have the
natural circles of people and
networks that were really
deep pockets, that we
could really look for.
So what happened-- one day, we
actually met a really unique
angel investor.
And she came to us because her
husband actually was mandated
into community service for
some tax problems.
And she was committed to
doing a million-dollar
fundraiser for us.
And she actually came with some
credibility, because she
actually had raised $1 million
for a racetrack, where she had
this thing where she auctioned
off horse sperm from a very
famous horse, and she
raised $1 million.
So we're like, OK, go for it.
And she came back several months
later, and she says, I
don't think that the fundraiser
for $1 million is
going to work, but I have an
idea for you that's going to
make you much more than that.
And Charles, our founder,
basically looked and said, OK,
what is it?
And she says, I want you to open
a thrift store for people
like me and my friends.
Now Charles thought this was
a little counterintuitive.
This was a very well-heeled lady
from the Upper East Side.
And it didn't really
make sense to him.
But she was committed.
She says, I will stake the
first thrift store.
And she put up $150,000.
And Charles, not looking
a gift horse in the
mouth, said, let's go.
So we opened our first thrift
store in 1992 on 18th Street.
We had a short-term lease,
because the landlord didn't
think it was a very
good idea either.
We did a break-even analysis
that said if in the first
three months, we made $24,000,
we would break even.
So the first two weeks, we
actually exceeded our $24,000.
And really, social enterprise
in Housing
Works was off and running.
So in the '90s we added a couple
more thrift stores.
In 1996, we actually added
a catering company.
In 1998, we added the
Bookstore Cafe.
We continued to add stores.
In 2004, we actually added
events that were shopping
events and related
to shopping.
And just this last year, we
opened our first outlet store
called Buy the Bag.
So all of this sort of totals
that we are now providing $25
million of funding to Housing
Works Services.
And this is about 44% of the
total revenue for the
organization.
So to really look at social
enterprise and what it really
meant to Housing Works, you kind
of look at some pivotal
moments in Housing
Works' histories.
So there were some threats that
sort of made us realize
how important social enterprise
was to us.
So the first threat was in
the form of this man.
Mayor Giuliani, in 1997, didn't
particularly like our
fierce brand of advocacy.
He didn't like that we were
protesting him and following
him around and demanding more
services and funding for
people living with
HIV and AIDS.
And he was very much determined
to put Housing
Works out of business.
At that time, we actually had
about 500 units of at city
housing contracts.
So we were housing 500 people
living with HIV and AIDS,
being funded by the city.
Mr. Giuliani, he sort
of turned his city
apparatus on us.
He went out and ordered audits,
and ultimately said we
were misappropriating funds and
took our contracts away.
So this actually almost
devastated Housing Works.
We were almost out
of business.
We had other services that
we were having a
tough time to pay for.
And if it weren't for the
businesses, we would not have
been able to survive.
Subsequently, we were able to
file a lawsuit against the
city and Mayor Giuliani.
And we won and we were awarded a
$5.9 million settlement with
the acknowledgement that the
contracts were taken back
without cause.
So we were on our way
and rebuilding.
And one thing that it really
made us double down on-- we
were always committed advocacy,
but now, we were
making sure that because of
the social enterprises, we
could really have an
independent voice.
We could speak truth to
power, and we were not
going to turn back.
So really, that was the first
point where social enterprise
really kept Housing Works
afloat, and it really made us
double down on the advocacy.
The second threat was
in 2008, when we
went through the recession.
So at that time, a lot of big
donors were either taking a
donor holiday, or they were
pulling back, or not funding
charities at all.
Many charities were actually
struggling.
Some had to close their doors.
Housing Works actually
weathered the
storm pretty well.
And we had an interesting
reaction.
We actually opened stores.
So in 2009, we opened three new
stores, and we decided to
grow our way out of this.
And so because of that, right
now we total about 80% of our
income is earned income.
So it's either from billing
Medicaid for health services
or from our businesses.
And that really makes it really
strong and powerful,
for Housing Works to have that
kind of self-sufficiency.
It's very much like
a submarine.
Submarines can go underwater and
they can power themselves
for months at a time.
And so sort of like a submarine,
Housing Works is
able to get through tough times
because we have this
reserve and immediate
cash flow.
There were times that we would
go right to the register, and
it would go right into the
services the very same day.
So it really is an immediacy
that was very valuable to us.
The next threat is really
going on now.
It's that the AIDS
crisis is over.
That there's awareness that's
sort of not there anymore.
Media is covering it
less and less.
And really, if HIV and AIDS is
getting to a manageable place,
the underpinnings of what makes
HIV and AIDS such a
devastating disease
is always there.
And that's homophobia, that's
racism, that's poverty.
So there will be another
opportunistic virus that will
take its place soon, once
HIV/AIDS is over, just like
there was always these things
present in our clients' lives.
So one of the things that our
businesses has done for us is
it's really created awareness.
So we were able to tap
into celebrity.
We're able to tap into a unique
group of people that
were in design and fashion, that
were hit hard because of
HIV and AIDS.
And we were able to sort of
keep the message going.
And because of our businesses,
we can draw attention to
issues that our clients
care about.
One of the things that the
social enterprise has really
done for the organization is
it's sort of been a little bit
of a culture clash.
So I want you to meet
our senior staff.
So our senior staff is obviously
not a cowboy and an
Indian, but they are chefs, they
are retail executives,
they are doctors,
they are social
service, social workers.
And because of this, there's
an incredible exchange of
ideas, an exchange
of cultures.
And undoubtedly, you're going
to influence each other.
So the social services are going
to influence the social
enterprise, and vice versa.
Two examples of how
this happened--
one is, our services really took
the brand of the ideas,
like, we built an
upscale thrift.
The idea was that we wanted to
create sort of a disruptive
image of what thrift-store
shopping was.
All of a sudden you think of it
is as sort of disorganized,
and a bunch of things that
no one else wanted.
And we really took it as
retailing, that this is
something that you want
to go in and it's an
exciting place to shop.
Very much so that we
carried that brand
over into or our services.
You see up on the right
is one of our
housing projects in Harlem.
And it is filled with Herman
Miller and Knoll Furniture.
The idea is that you can make
deals with those vendors.
They're much better quality.
They will last longer,
instead of a
replacement of cheap furniture.
And our clients will respond so
much better to it, and they
will find that they will take
care of things because you're
surrounding them with
beautiful things.
And why should low-income
housing look
like low-income housing?
Same thing with our
health centers.
Many health centers are dark
and dim, and they're not
lighting, and they're
not infused with
great customer service.
So because we were doing retail
business that we had to
be so competitive, we actually
were able to bring some of
those sensibilities
into our services.
And another way, the opposite,
that the social services, how
that affected our social
enterprise, was sort of back
to the '90s.
People were starting to get
drugs in themselves, and they
were starting to feel
like life extended.
And they wanted to get
back into life.
There was a future for
people living with
HIV and AIDS again.
And they wanted employment.
At that time, Housing Works
would have sort of
peer jobs for them.
They would be a messenger,
or they would clean up
afterwards.
But they weren't really
sustainable, and they were
very part-time.
So they actually, in the spirit
of Housing Works, they
actually did a sit-in in our
CEO's office, and they
demanded employment services.
So out of that, our job training
program started.
It was one of the first job
training programs for people
living with HIV and AIDS
in the country.
It was unique in the fact that
after a nine-month period
where you were getting your GED
and on-the-job training,
you were actually guaranteed
a job in Housing Works.
So 15% of our employees
are former clients.
This has a huge impact on how
we view the businesses, how
all this works together.
The walls came down between
clients and staff.
Clients were able to sort of
mentor and empower themselves,
as well as give back
to future clients.
And staff and managers were able
to really look at, this
is what we're fighting for and
this is who we're serving,
right alongside each other.
So that was really a very
powerful thing that, from the
other side, social services
really impacted social
enterprise.
You don't usually run businesses
like that, and
that's what makes Housing
Works unique.
So some of our learnings of
how we got into social
enterprise, it wasn't something
that we sought out.
It was something that sort
of fell into our lap.
It's not necessarily for
every organization.
People think it's just sort
of free, easy money.
It really takes a lot to do, and
there's a lot of conflicts
and waves along the way.
One of the first ones is
actually the tension between
the social services and
social enterprises.
There's always a tension
for resources.
Non-profits are not
traditionally funded well.
So when you do have resources,
there's always sort
of a fight for them.
Social services, they need
the resources right
now to provide services.
Social enterprise needs
resources to invest so they
can get more profit down the
line, and to keep it going and
to keep innovating.
And it's also the idea of--
this idea of where you earn your
money is very different
than where you're spending
your money.
So when you look at how you have
to reorient your whole
organization, about how you
recruit, how you brand
yourself, it's really about what
kind of culture that you
make out of this.
So that was really our first
learning, is that tension that
you have to make sure that, if
you're going into social
enterprise, you do.
The second thing is that social
enterprise, you don't
make money off of the mission.
That's not why people
are shopping for us.
It might be a little bit why
they donate to us, but they
certainly shop because we
have a good product.
Our prices are well.
They're clean stores, they're
entertaining.
We always have something new.
That's why people are
shopping, not
because of the mission.
This is not like the other areas
of the organization, our
social justice part,
with advocacy,
or our social services.
That's really where your brand,
you're leading with
your mission.
So it a little bit differently,
and you really
have to understand that you're
being competitive in the most
competitive city in the
world in retail.
And if you can survive that,
you have to play by those
rules, not by the rules that you
would like people to shop
for you because they
like your mission.
Another learning--
this could be a negative--
is that social enterprise can
overshadow your social services.
If you google our Housing Works,
you're going to have to
get many pages in before you
get anything significant on
our social services.
So this can be a problem for
sort of getting the word out
about what else you do, because
you're so popular in
social enterprise.
We did about 500 million media
impressions last year, just on
our social enterprises.
So that was just something that
sort of can overwhelm it.
And even internal to the AIDS
industry, this can be true.
We were at an event, and our
CEO introduced our chief
medical officer to the then
doctor at St. Vincent's.
And he looked a little confused
about, why would you
have a doctor at
a thrift store?
So he obviously didn't even see
that beyond the Housing
Works, you had all these
different services that made
us the largest AIDS service
provider in New York state.
So it's something that
you have to balance.
And sometimes media awareness
doesn't always go the way you
want it to.
And then perseverance.
I think that one of the great
stories of Housing Works and
social enterprise is
our Bookstore Cafe.
So we did open a bookstore
cafe in 1998.
We did this because we
were full of books.
We had three thrift stores and
they were sort of clogging up
all of our storage space.
So we decided we were going
to open a bookstore cafe.
And we invested a couple hundred
thousand dollars in
it, and it's a beautiful
space.
If you haven't been there, it's
really one of the gems of
New York City.
And the only problem with it is
for the next six years, it
didn't make money.
It actually was losing money.
And so here, something that was
supposed to bring money to
the mission is actually drawing
from the mission.
So that's a huge problem.
But we stayed with it.
We knew there was potential
in the business.
And 2003, we acquired a software
and we started
selling books online.
And now we sell more books
online than we do in the
stores, and we started
becoming profitable.
And then there was one more
piece to the story, is that
our space was really
beautiful.
And we did concerts and
cultural events.
But we really thought there
was a way that we could
exploit the space
and make money.
At the same time, we had our
other business, which was our
catering company.
It was hanging around.
It was plodding along, it was
doing well, it was profitable.
But we decided that if we take
our catering and we take our
event space, and why don't
we market weddings?
So we started to market weddings
starting in 2009, and
we started getting all
this response.
You get a unique wedding
that's really still
inexpensive for New York City
in the heart of Soho.
And just this year,
we booked and
produced about 70 weddings.
So that's just another way
to just be adaptable.
You have to find it.
If you're going to be in social
enterprise, it's not
always easy.
There's times that
you lose money.
There's time that you
have to adapt.
There's times that you have
to show patience.
So these were sort of what they
meant to Housing Works.
And this is our journey
of Housing Works.
In fact, it was a mission
that was not--
we didn't start out as a
mission, but in 2009, we
actually added social enterprise
to our official
mission statement.
So now it's relentless advocacy,
the provision of
lifesaving services, and
entrepreneurial businesses
that sustain our efforts.
So this was our journey with
social enterprise.
And that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW BERNARDO: So is that
20 minutes or a half hour?
So do you have any questions?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering-- so
is there an average cost that
you can share with us for the
average wedding, any of the 70
that happened there?
MATTHEW BERNARDO: It's
about $20,000.
So the space is $750
an hour, sometimes.
So in the end, that's
about $5,000.
And then about $15,000 for food
and staff and rentals.
So--
AUDIENCE: We're getting married,
so that's a very
[INAUDIBLE].
MATTHEW BERNARDO: Oh, is it?
OK.
Yeah.
I mean for a New York City
wedding, it's still very,
very, very reasonable.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: And you [INAUDIBLE].
MATTHEW BERNARDO:
It seats 150.
It gets 350 for buffet style.
So it's a really interesting
thing, especially--
all the other stuff is cleared
out, and the books are sort of
the wallpaper, which really
makes it beautiful.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
if you already
mentioned this, so apologies.
But how many treatment
centers do you have
versus retail stores?
MATTHEW BERNARDO: We have
13 retail stores,
including Buy the Bag.
And then we have a
Bookstore Cafe.
So that's 14 in all.
And we have a four
health centers.
Obviously, the health centers
are much, much larger.
And they're mostly in Manhattan
and Brooklyn.
And then we have
housing units.
We have 151 units of independent
housing.
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
One, your early anecdote about
your first angel investor, you
said she told you she wanted you
to start a thrift shop for
people like her?
Did you ever find out exactly
what she meant?
MATTHEW BERNARDO: She
meant that it was an
upscale thrift store.
That the idea was that she
actually had the model.
That the model of the thrift
store is that we actually go
in and we go into very expensive
neighborhoods,
because we get donations
from that neighborhood.
And we then sell it to the same
people that are in that
neighborhood.
So everything in retail
is about the product.
So if we start out with a good
product and actually have the
donations that are high-end,
you're going to be able to
have a lot easier time
than selling it.
So that's what she meant.
She actually was right on.
AUDIENCE: You didn't show those
pictures of the upscale
thrift store.
Those didn't come later
in your presentation.
Was the very first thrift store,
did it have that same
[INAUDIBLE]?
Was it in an upscale
neighborhood?
MATTHEW BERNARDO: Yeah, it was
on 18th Street and 7th Avenue.
And then that lasted about six
months, and then we moved into
17th Street, which is
our flagship store.
And it's on 17th between
Sixth and Seventh.
And the idea was that we had a
couple things going for us.
One is that we were able to
beautifully merchandise it.
So we believed in merchandising
products.
So our product were always had
these elaborate displays and
sort of a quirkiness.
Each of our stores is sort of a
mirror to the neighborhood.
So our Upper East Side store
and Chelsea are going to be
merchandised differently.
So we had that.
And remember, at the time, there
were many people that
were dying of HIV and AIDS.
And we might not have been
getting the currency of their
cash, but we were certainly
getting their estates and all
of the furniture and clothing
that they were bequeathing us.
So that really was able to
sort of seed a very good
product base for us.
And then it sort of caught fire,
and we were able to go,
we ended up going online through
our auctions, and
growing from there.
AUDIENCE: I have a second
question, if that's OK.
When you were talking about the
bookstore, you said it was
unprofitable for the first few
years, and then you took off
when you started selling
stuff online.
So my question is, at that
point, from a business point
of view, how do you justify
the bookstore's continued
existence, once you find out
that at least at that point,
the real money's in
online sales?
MATTHEW BERNARDO: Well, because
of the bookstore, we
were doing the online sales in
the basement, so it was part
of the whole rent.
The bookstore was producing
revenue.
It's just it wasn't
necessarily--
it was right around break-even
or losing money.
And the bookstore brought
a lot of extra
things into the bookstore.
Like we had authors
that we'd get.
It would garner a lot
of media attention.
We had concerts.
We have John Mellencamp, John
Cougar Mellencamp that played
there, and Bjork DJed there.
So there's a lot of things that
we could rationalize that
we were getting the awareness
out through it.
And we were just sort of not
making it as a great business
proposition.
Certainly, the time and energy
we were sinking into it wasn't
paying off in the first
couple years.
But we believed in it.
We believed as part of the
social enterprise, that there
was a way to make money, and
we would try a lot of
different things.
Now we have a cafe that's
growing, and we have the
online that's growing,
and we have the
events that are growing.
So it's sort of like,
sometimes you have
to figure it out.
And sometimes just dumping it
costs more money there anyway.
Because you have rents and
leases and so forth.
AUDIENCE: So you kind of
discussed how the financial
crisis in 2008 kind of, in
a way, I wouldn't say
vindicated, but supported the
social enterprise model, which
is [INAUDIBLE].
Like in large part also saving
financially while maintaining
your mission and goal.
Do you think that that message
still resonates today?
Or do you think because of the
recovery, NGOs are kind of
going back to donor focus
and development?
MATTHEW BERNARDO: Well, I think
there's two things.
One is that it's not completely
proven to the
letter of the theory.
But the theory is that
secondhand stores can be a
little bit counter-cyclical
with the recession.
So as people are sort of
looking for options to
exercise their shopping muscle,
they're looking at
other places that are
a better value.
So with it, for example, 15% of
the people decided to shop
secondhand stores for
the first time.
So people started being
introduced to
this in some ways.
And so we do do slightly better
than regular mainline
retail on that.
The second thing, as far as
traditional fundraising, we
really didn't have a traditional
development
department until like 2004.
And what we learned is very much
similar to how we merged
the bookstore and the catering
to make it work.
The businesses are really the
front door to our development
department.
Now we are doing traditional
development at a better clip.
We're getting individual
donors.
We started a membership program
that actually is in
all the stores.
So that was the first way that
people were actually giving
cash instead of just
giving product.
Our events brings a really
well-heeled community into the
events, and we start
working them and
bringing them out to lunches.
And we're starting to get some
multiple-figure donations, in
terms of the estates.
Last year, we were able
to get an anonymous
donation for $750,000.
That was the first time we've
ever had something that large.
So really, the businesses were
our front door to development.
So we're taking advantage
of it wherever
they're coming in from.
So we're getting much more
sophisticated about our
development now, so.
AUDIENCE: You had a graph
that showed [INAUDIBLE].
Why do you think that is?
MATTHEW BERNARDO: Well, it was
that you were dying faster,
and that the circumstances of
being really vulnerable
allowed you to have
entree into this
opportunistic disease.
So again, it goes back to sort
of, if you are not housed,
then you are living
a chaotic life.
When you're living a chaotic
life, you're more likely to
get into situations that
you're finding
opportunistic disease.
The story of HIV and
AIDS cannot be
told without poverty.
It cannot be told
without racism.
And it cannot be told
without homophobia.
If you look at where it sort of
spread from, it started in
the gay community, and now it's
mostly in the people of
color and that's where it's
sort of transferred to.
So you start seeing
a lot of these
underpinnings with the disease.
AUDIENCE: How long ago did
Housing Works implement the
auctions that they have
[INAUDIBLE] storefronts?
MATTHEW BERNARDO: We always
had auctions.
We did it as paper auctions.
So there was a time when people
would, we would always
do these windows, and people
would go in and they write
down the auction, and there was
a time that it would end,
and everyone would crowd around
for the winning bid.
And literally, people were at
the register, putting their
last bid, and then that's
how it was.
So we then decided, well, that's
really only good for
individual stores,
and we're only
drawing from that community.
So we decided to put
them online, and
we did online auctions.
And we have
shophousingworks.com, which
does about $1 and 1/2 million
a year through our auctions.
And it opened up the base.
Now we have people all over the
country that actually buy
from it, and we ship
to most places.
We have people in other
countries that
are buying from us.
And also, the auctions were a
great way to sort of be a
check on that we're getting
the right price.
Because it really is
an open market.
So we had an example--
once we had this piece of art
that we were going to price.
We priced it at $25.
We threw it in the auction.
We figured it'll go
where it goes.
$17,000 later, we realized that
this was a piece of art
that was worth it.
I'm sure we've had something
slip through our fingers, and
that's part of thrifting.
That's part of the game.
That's part of the hunt, that
people want to find these
great things.
But the online auctions have
really helped us put things
that we're not sure about on a
bigger market that we can get
the most for.
AUDIENCE: That's a great
way of putting it.
Like things that you're
not quite sure about.
MATTHEW BERNARDO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because yeah, you
walk by, and you get that
impression that there have got
to be some things that are
true [INAUDIBLE], really.
Oh, maybe I could have found
it in Housing Works in the
not-auction area.
I've had a few wins there.
MATTHEW BERNARDO: Yeah, yeah.
That's good, that's good.
But generally, the rule is
anything signed, we try to put
in window so we can do that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATTHEW BERNARDO: All right.
Well, thank you very
much for your time.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]